proposed changes to calico basin we
first told you about the plans from the
bureau of land management last month it
would allow the consideration of an
entry fee for now that trail within red
rock canyon is free to visit and locals
are taking a stand in hopes of keeping
it that way tonight i heard from a local
group leading that push
me and my family been coming out here
for years calico basin
it's a popular destination for climbers
and hikers like drake hickey there's
really nowhere else to go where you can
just decompress after working all day
it's one of the few free open trails
within red rock canyon but that could
soon change
in may the blm finalized a recreation
management plan for the area which
allows the consideration of a fee
program and reservation system it seems
not in line of what the public really
wants brian friesen is the president of
southern nevada climbers coalition
this week they joined fellow climbing
organization access fund to appeal the
blm's proposal as they believe
restrictions like this could cause
problems it might push some of those
people out to the other areas like first
creek that don't have the same
facilities and really could start
getting trashed instead they hope to
come to a compromise and promote
education and preservation the desert is
extremely sensitive and if people are
trampling around
you know that does create an issue so
people like hickey can continue to enjoy
everything our beautiful desert has to
offer
the blm is holding two public meetings
next week where they are looking for
public input on proposed changes
including calico basin